Hello Dr Peterson,
thank you very much.
And my question is regarding Adhd,
which is something I haven't heard you
speak a whole lot about,
maybe a little bit.
Um,
now it seems to me that we are at least
maybe just me do not quite understand
adhd to what could be its full capacity
maybe and because there's many,
many voices saying that it's an
overdiagnosed overblown small mental
variants that's prevalent in boys or
it's just young boys being young boys
and then there are some that would fight
and advocate for a very different
treatment in the academic world.
And I was wondering what you,
what your thoughts are on Adhd itself.
Um,
and on the,
whether you think it's overdiagnosed and
maybe advice for me as someone who has
been diagnosed with adhd on how to
overcome it without maybe becoming
completely reliant on prescribed
medication.
Okay.
So first of all,
it's definitely overdiagnosed.
Second,
it's very unreliable.
Psychiatric diagnosis.
Many psychiatric diagnosis are
unreliable and that's because
psychiatric diagnosis aren't precisely
scientific categories.
They're weird hybrids,
right?
First of all,
psychiatrists aren't scientists.
They're engineers.
Engineers are trying to do something
rather than to describe the objective
world and psychiatrists are trying to
make people healthy.
Whatever that means.
It's actually partly ethical.
It's very complicated.
We don't know how to distinguish it from
temperamental variation,
so for example,
if you're high in openness and high in
extroversion and low in
conscientiousness,
low in agreeableness,
conscientiousness and and high in
neuroticism,
you're likely to manifest symptoms of
Adhd.
It's because your exploratory,
you don't like to sit down,
you're full of ideas.
Your attention scatters across a wide
variety of topics and you're not very
stable.
Temperamental variation is also much
more common among boys.
Panksepp showed same guy with rats that
if you deprive young routes of rough and
tumble play,
which is what the young boys are
deprived of in school,
let's say that they get hyperactive and
then their prefrontal cortex is don't
develop very well because they're not
having the right kind of experiences and
that you can treat that quite
effectively with psychomotor stimulants
like Ritalin.
So that's kind of an interesting bit of
scientific information that no one pays
any attention to.
There is also absolutely no evidence
whatsoever that longterm use of
psychomotor stimulants produces
increases in cognitive gain,
zero,
and there's plenty of evidence that it's
harmful.
So then the second part of that was what
about,
yeah,
adjustments for in the academic world,
say disability adjustments.
It's like,
that's such a rat's nest that I don't
want to even discuss it.
I mean it,
it,
I'll discuss it for like 15 seconds.
There is a never ending multiplication
of disability.
That's what's happening right now.
The disability offices in the
universities are swamp.
Like I know some people have it rough,
like believe me,
I know that I,
I,
I seriously know that I've dealt with
extraordinarily damaged people in my
life.
You,
you're,
you're bloody hard pressed to find
someone who doesn't have a serious
problem or who doesn't have a serious
problem in a close family member.
It's like,
where do you draw the line with regards
to disability where you can't,
you can't.
They multiply just like lgbt identities.
Multiply.
Just knows.
She really technically just like that.
Just like intersectionality categories
of oppression multiply.
It's,
it's,
it's inevitable the way that you deal
with it.
As you have objective standards,
you apply them to everyone.
Not because that's fair.
It's not fair.
If you.
If your criteria for fairness is that
everyone has the same outcome.
It's not fair at all.
It's not even close to fair.
It's just less piratical than the
alternatives.
Now we don't know that yet because we
haven't seen the full range of the
tyranny of the alternatives manifests
itself,
not in our culture,
but it certainly did in other cultures.
I think it's a bad idea now.
I don't want to be absolute about that.
Like it's tricky,
you know,
because if you have a disability
that
would allow you to do the work in the
university and in the workplace with a
modification,
then perhaps the modification could be
made,
but I think that was done a lot better
when I was in the hands of the
professors and not in the hands of these
crazy bureaucratic structures that have
risen up around the disability issue.
Like they're one of the 10 things that
are going to kill the universities or
maybe have already killed them possibly
because they made their walking corpses
as far as I can tell zombies,
so and that might be wrong,
but that's what it looks like to me
versus I want to say thank you so much
is an amazing talk and I was wondering
if you could elaborate.
What I noticed a lot,
I go here to UBC is that a lot of
students and young people,
they're often desensitized to,
for example,
the atrocities that communism or
ideologies that forced terrorism and
maybe it's some sort of Stockholm
syndrome that I'm seeing where it's like
people are just there,
they're like trapped and they can't.
They feel in way they can do anything
about it and then they start to like,
like,
like communism or they start to see more
social or adopt socialist policy that in
the end we'll get them killed.
We'll get them hurt.
As long as you kind of elaborate on what
you think can be done about that or even
if something can be done in that
respect.
Well,
I think something can be done.
I mean,
I've been trying to educate people about
the horrors of the Nazi regime in the
Soviet regime in particular.
I've concentrated mostly on those two
cars,
but that's good enough and trying to let
people know that it was through the
fault of people,
much like them,
that those systems are rows and,
and that there are steps you can take to
limit the probability that you would
participate in such a thing and that
those steps are associated with trying
to be truthful in your speech and
actions because the stability of those
systems depends on the willingness of
individuals to lie and,
and also on your willingness to take
responsibility for the malevolence in
your own heart.
That manifests itself in those social
movements.
And so that when I've done,
when I do my lectures,
when I do talks like this,
when I put them on Youtube,
what I'm trying to do is exactly that
because that was the best pathway
forward through such things that I could
think up over 20 years of thinking about
it.
Um,
you know,
one is so habituated to suffering that
they can read the Gulag archipelago,
which is actually quite hard to read
without having an effect them like your
psychopathic.
If that book doesn't affect you,
you know,
it should,
if you read it properly,
it affects you deeply.
And it's not the only example of that
kind of literature.
So the people who are habituated aren't,
they've just been shown low resolution
representations of things they don't
understand that looked vaguely bad.
They don't know a damn thing about them.
And our education system has done a
tremendously appalling job of educating
young people about the absolute
catastrophe of radical leftism.
Now it's not much better with regards to
say the actions of the Nazis,
although I would say on average people
are more aware of that,
but they don't.
But it's shallow,
shallow knowledge.
So you make the knowledge deep and deep
knowledge changes people and wakes them
up.
You know?
I mean,
the only reason that I ever got
convinced that they're that good and
evil,
we're real more,
more real than anything else wasn't
because I learned that good was real.
That's hard.
It's hard to learn that you have to find
examples of transcendent good,
you know,
they're rare,
evil.
All you have to do is look,
read history a bit and read it like it's
about you and there's no way that you
can do that without a transformation,
but people won't do it.
It's like you want to imagine yourself
as an Auschwitz guard.
That's a rough thing you see because you
have to figure out,
see young set,
if you confronted the shadow,
which was the dark side of people,
the aggressive side,
the malevolent side,
that it,
it really reaches all the way down to
hell and Dante sort of was trying to put
forward the same thing when he wrote the
inferno,
right?
With the levels of evil,
Because it was a voyage through the
levels of evil,
right to the bottom.
He thought the bottom was betrayal.
It's pretty good.
The,
the most,
the center of malevolence as betrayal.
I liked that because to be trained
someone,
you have to get them to trust you,
and trust is a moral virtue,
right?
Especially if it's courageous trust,
because it it,
it puts you in alignment with other
people and allows you to move forward
into life and if you'd be trained that
you really,
it's like a knife in the.
It's like knife in the heart,
through the back,
especially if it's someone who loves,
loves you,
betrays you,
and especially if they be trey you for
your virtues.
That's a really nice twist.
So I believe because I think that people
are capable of good,
that if they know enough about evil that
that will straighten them out.
So,
but who wants that?
You know,
this is one of the things I really like
about young.
He's often regarded as a new age
thinker.
That's wrong.
He's no new age thinker.
He knew that the,
the pathway to enlightenment was barred
by the necessity of a passage through
hell and that no one was going to do
that.
That's why there isn't a world full of
enlightened people.
You might say like it was just a matter
of doing nice things following your
bliss.
Let's say however you might put it.
Then why wouldn't everyone walk up the
stairway to heaven?
That isn't how it works.
That's not how it works at all.
I don't think you can be convinced of
the necessity for moral action until you
understand exactly how dark and terrible
things can get and that it's your fault
that they're getting that way.
Who wants to think that?
So you can think it though,
but not.
Not Without it burning you.
So thanks.